Thank you to all the patrons and backers who make the podcast possible.
I want to tell you you can join them by going to scoutmasterscgcom and clicking
the support link at the top of the page.
And now it's the old scout master.
Just the other day I discussed a number of points about orienteering with my
scouts. Now, if they comb their hair correctly, nobody will notice those
points. but yeah, points, orienteering.
Thank you, I think, for the inspiration to for that one to listen
to Bill McFarland, I think maybe.
Anyway, this is podcast number 358..
Welcome back to the scout master podcast. It's me, Clark Green.
Today. I have a couple of email questions to answer, but before I do, I just
want to tell you that this podcast is being published on December 4th and
then we'll have another couple of podcasts and then we'll take
a couple of weeks off for the holidays and return to you early next
year with a series- yes, a series- about some of the foundational concepts of
scouting. I don't think I've ever actually done that before,
Usually just to answer an email questions or talking about whatever
comes to mind. I'm going to take a little bit of a structured approach
for a few podcasts early next year, just to kind of start from square
one and build a foundation for being a effective scouter.
So that'll probably be like: maybe five, maybe three, maybe one, two, five, three.
So that will be an as yet to be determined. maybe five?
Two weapons are fear and surprise, and ruthless
Lysificiency of three weapons are fear and surprise, and ruthless
efficiency and an almost fanatical devotion to the pope are four
Amongst our. well, could be more. three sounds about right,
Yeah, but come to think of it, it's probably going to take more than three.
Well, anyway, we'll get there.
Okay, we'll get there one way or the other,
But for now I have a couple of email questions to answer.
So let's get started. Shall we send it by email?
That is, folks, And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Here's the first email question.
I have a young scout who just got scout rank signed off two weeks ago
and asked for at least 10 merit badge blue cards.
His parents have signed him up for merit badge events
And I wonder if mom and dad are doing more than he is.
I know my role as scout master is to determine whether or not
the merit badge counselor is registered before I sign the blue cards
And I get to have a short conference with the scout as to what he's doing,
And his mother has been involved with these talks
And she emphasizes- her and her husband are helping him out
because he has some help at school through an individualized
education program or an IEP.
I suspect mom and dad are doing too much
And maybe he's not getting anything out of the program.
What do you suggest I do?
Ah well, that question should have the ring of familiarity with many of us.
So before I offer any advice, ask yourself these two questions.
Number one: did you choose your parents?
And number two: if I tell you how to work with your children,
how would you react to that?
Would you welcome that as helpful advice,
Or would you perhaps see it as something else?
So as you ponder the answers to those two questions,
I know it's difficult to figure out what we're able to do in some
situations when parents are doing things, or at least seem to be doing things,
You kind of. rather, they didn't.
All the parents I've worked with over the years did at least something
that I found either puzzling or alarming or just kind of tiresome.
I can't recall any instance where any attempt to correct their
parenting came out very well. just to let you know,
And I'm not saying that all concerns are totally misplaced,
but you have to put these in the context of what we're doing
and what the scouts doing and the parents, who he has not chosen, are doing.
So it's almost certain that the scout is not being harmed by doing
merit badges and what an individual parent chooses to do is not going
to harm the merit badge program. merit badge program is pretty resilient
But, as you noted, every time you sign a blue card
you have the opportunity to discuss what's going on with the scout
and just keep that casual and see if you can begin to understand
what he might be getting out of the whole process.
Sometimes scouts get a lot out of the process,
Sometimes they get a little, and some are certainly
collecting merit badges like Pokemon cards.
Now you can think that that's good or that's bad,
But, like I say, is the scout being harmed by doing merit badges
or is he able to inflict harm on the program itself?
Probably not.
None of us have the ability to look into another family
and see exactly what's going on.
You may think the parents are overreaching,
being a little too ambitious or over involved,
And you know what.
Sometimes that's the case, but they're trying to figure
things out as best that they can,
And the scout may be getting a whole lot out of this
that you don't see it first blush.
Going through the whole merit badge thing may be helping
him with any challenges he has so far as learning is concerned.
It could be helping him and his parents have an activity
that they can participate in together and that they enjoy.
I mean, we may never understand or know what's going on.
Now there are rules, you know. like any game,
There are rules.
We follow the rules,
And when it comes to evaluating who's doing the work
and who isn't, well, that's up to the merit badge counselor,
isn't it? That's not up to us.
And if, and only if, there was ample evidence to find
that there was something untoward going on here,
I don't know whether I would stir this particular pot.
I would better advise to observe what's going on,
talk to the scout and see if that changes the way
that you perceive the situation.
Along the same lines of scouts, advancement and their parents,
I had an email that I'll summarize by saying that it deals
with a scout who is very ambitious himself and has very ambitious
parents, apparently, and they're probably driving pretty hard
to get him to Eagle Scout.
He's involved in a lot of activities outside of scouting
And there are a few concerns that this raises
with his scout master.
That's pretty broad strokes about the situation
And, at face value, like most of you,
this kind of situation would rub me the wrong way
and I can identify with that sense of frustration.
But laying all the frustrations and the personalities aside,
a demanding thing to do at times. what are the real issues?
Well, we know that scouts advance by fulfilling a list of requirements.
of those requirements,
Most of them are defined metrics.
In other words, there's not a whole lot of ambiguity
about how you fulfill the requirement.
If it's 10 nights of camping, you go camping for 10 nights,
Not that big a deal-
And a few advancement requirements don't have a set metric
And so you have to make a judgment call as to whether a
scout has fulfilled them or not.
Now, I most commonly hear about these judgment calls when we
talk about active participation and quote leadership, unquote-
and more about that in a moment- positions,
And I hear about them pretty often because these are two
things that are not real easy to understand about scouting.
Now, whenever somebody asked me about quote leadership, positions,
unquote, I am quick to point out two things.
The first is is the requirements refer to positions of
responsibility, not leadership?
The guide to advancement explains the importance of
differentiating between leadership and responsibility and
puts emphasis on responsibility.
The second thing is: the only rank requirement that explicitly
requires the demonstration of leadership is found in the
Eagle project.
I also want to note that the guide to advancement discusses
factoring in activities outside of scouting in our evaluations
of responsibility for others and an active participation.
So before I go further, it would be important for me to
note- I will have a link to the guide to advancement in the
podcast notes.
If you have not spent significant time with the guide to
advancement and you haven't at least scanned it and read
those sections that are relevant to your work in scouting,
you really need to do that,
And then you need to keep it handy so you can go back and
refer to them.
It's not because of the complexity of the rules,
which are kind of complex in some situations, but the
principles that are very clearly expressed in the guide that
inform the way that you work with your scouts.
These are really important things.
Get the guide to advancement, look through it and
especially study and read those areas that concern your
role in scouting
And these issues around participation and
responsibility are something that are useful to discuss
with your fellow scouts.
I think most of us act on assumptions about these
things that don't jive with the very clear directions
we're given in the guide to advancement and those
assumptions run up against some of the things that the
guide to advancement says and that will cause a little
friction. but it's important to make sure that we are
clear on exactly how these two things work
And once we're clear on that, we understand a broad
underlying principle that advancement is not the
scout versus the judgment of adult volunteers.
It's the scout and adult volunteers being
supportive versus the requirements.
I want to say that again,
Advancement is not about the scout satisfying the
judgment of adult volunteers.
It's about the scout and supportive adult volunteers
finding a way for the scout to satisfy the requirements.
We are all on the same side.
Now, you and I did not write the rank requirements.
We don't personally embroider patches to present to
our scouts.
These are something whether we agree with them or
not, whether we particularly like them or not. it's
all part of the deal.
It's all part of your commitment and loyalty
to the program to understand how these things
work and it's really tiresome and self-defeating
to devise our own hoops for our scouts to jump
through or to impose our own judgment on the
scouts when there are better ways to get the job done.
In my book there are two basic approaches to
advancement judgment calls.
So the first one is establishing a metric or a
number that all scouts have to meet.
So when we're talking about participation, you
got to make this percentage of events and this
percentage of meetings, things like that.
That's one solution.
The second basic approach is setting an
individual goal, in consultation with the
scout and sometimes, when it's appropriate, with
their parents.
Now, having tried both approaches, I prefer
setting an individual goal with and not for the
scout.
So let me emphasize that we're setting a goal
with the scout, not for the scout.
If we just come up with a metric that feels
right and we say that's going to apply to all
scouts, that's setting a goal for them.
If we instead take a very little bit of time,
listen to what a scout has to say, inquire of his
parents or his family when that's appropriate,
will come up with an individualized goal that
makes a whole lot more sense, that will fulfill
the requirement just fine
And that takes about, you know, 10 minutes.
We sit down, we talk to the scout about the
goals that they would set for themselves to
fulfill the active and responsibility aspects
of the requirements.
And that begins with questions, not statements.
Just to give you a shorthand approach. if I
was doing this with a scout, I would sit down
with them and I would ask them to read me
the requirements in question, while a scout
participate actively in your troop and patrol
for X number of months or occupy a position
of responsibility for X number of months.
So we would be very clear on the exact
wording of the two requirements.
And then, before I offered any, my thoughts
on it, I would ask the scout to explain
the requirements to me and how they
understood them and what kind of goal
they were setting for themselves to
fulfill the requirement.
And I would listen carefully to what they
have to say, because what they have to say
is going to reveal any number of things.
It's going to reveal something about the
relationship that they have with their
parents, if that's applicable. it's
going to reveal somewhat of their
relationship they have with the
scouting program, with the things that
they do outside of scouts,
And I'm going to get a better picture
of what's realistic and appropriate
for that individual scout and
fulfilling those requirements.
So once I've asked them how they
arrived at that goal, if it makes
sense to me, we're done,
And if it doesn't, I'm going to ask
more questions.
And if I do more listening than
speaking- which is very difficult for
me- I will get some insight into his
life and I'll help him find a way
to make things work.
And that's what we're all about.
Remember, we're all on the same side
here. Now, in this instance, the
author of the email explained to
me at length about how difficult
these particular parents are,
And some parents are difficult.
Oh well, they may be overreaching,
They may be driving pretty hard,
They may be over involved
And you know, looking from the
outside in, it's easy to judge
that other parents are doing things
wrong. Of course, they're looking
back at us and judging how we're
missing the mark,
And we'd really rather that parents
just understood what we're trying
to do and agree with our judgment.
But that doesn't always happen,
Because some parents are just hell
bent on their child becoming an
evil scout. OK, that happens.
Some look for loopholes to get
this checked off their list as
quickly as possible.
Yes, that happens
And it can be extraordinarily
frustrating And we might try to
explain things and they might
reject them
And that you know they kind
of lawyer their way around the
whole thing.
It's frustrating, I get it,
But we shouldn't allow our
frustration with a scout's parents
to color our relationship with
the scout. Remember what I said
earlier: Tell me when you picked
your parents. scouts don't get to
do that. If we aren't careful,
we'll express the frustration
with a scout's parents by using
their scout as a pawn to prove a
point to the parents, who
probably aren't going to appreciate
the point that we're trying to
prove anyway.
So the scout didn't choose his
parents and battling them only
harms the scout.
So, rather than being frustrated by
parents who act this way,
what if we embraced their
ambitions for their son?
We get everybody on the same side
of the question and we make being
in our troop valuable,
relatively simple to do and
satisfies their ambitions,
because that's kind of the kind
thing to do for the scout,
isn't it?
Power struggles with parents
only hurt scouts.
They're really aggravating.
They cause unnecessary upset.
See if you can get everybody
on board headed in the same
direction. I mean, the
requirements are right there in
black and white. Don't color
them with your judgment.
Appeal to the scout for their
judgment, set a mutually
agreeable goal and everybody
should be relatively happy.
You know, if you've listened to
the podcast for a while, you've
heard me talk about this exact
thing a number of times, but I
always think it's worth
repeating because, like I said
earlier, this is one of the
harder things to get about
the work that we do,
And I appreciate how difficult
it is. It took me a long time
to get to the point where I
could work with a minimum
of frustration- not totally
absent frustration with
parents like these- and make
the experience of being a
scout in our troop as
advantageous to the scout as
was humanly possible.
If you have a question for me,
I'd love to hear from you.
It's very easy to get in touch.
I'm always available at
clark at scoutmastercgcom.
That's C L A R K E at
scoutmastercgcom.
You can find us also on Facebook
and Twitter. Come on over to
scoutmastercgcom,
Check out the resources that
we have for you there
And, while you're there,
consider becoming a patron
or a backer. Just click the
support link at the top of
the page. Thanks to all of you.
make it possible, And all that
remains for me to do today is
to be sure that we hear from
our founder, Sir Robert
Baden Powell. Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good
candy. Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time, everyone.